المنتخب المغربي يصنع التاريخ ويتاهل ربع
النهائي مونديال قطر مهاجم امريكا يرقص
بقميصه هولندا بعد توديع المونديال احلام
وبينيسيوس جونيور هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعونها على العربيه رياضه
[موسيقى]
نتحول الى بيان صموئيس الاتحاد الكاميروني
الرسميه والذي قدم فيه اعتذاره على واقعه
تعديه على احد المشجعين الجزائريين فقط
اسطوره الكاميرون اثار ضجه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي باعتدائه على مشجعا
اتهموه
لحكم مباراه منتخب بلاده ضد الجزائر في
الملحق المؤهل لمونديال قطر
اعتذر في البيان بسببي عدم ضبطه لتصرفاته
التي لن تتوافق مع مسؤوليته ومنصبه في
الاتحاد الكاميروني ولكنه شدد في الوقت
نفسه على تعرضه دائم للمضايقه من قبل
الجمهور الجزائري منذ مباراه المنتخب في
مارس الماضي
تداول رواد السوشيال ميديا فيديو
وهو يرقص في ملهى الليلي مرتديا قمصه
هولندا بعد توديع منتخب بلاده الامريكيه
للمونديال هذا التصرف المثير للجدل جاء
بعد ما تم استبعاد اللاعب وبشكل مفاجئ من
قائمه المنتخب الامريكي للمشارك في بطوله
العالميه ومن ثم توزيعه المونديال على يد
هولندا الانباء الصحفيه تضاربات حول السبب
الحقيقي وراء التصرف المهاجم الدولي البعض
منهم اشار الى انه جاء بدافع الانتقام من
عدم تواجده مع المنتخب فيما جار اخرون الى
ان السبب يعود لخساره ريكاردو
احد الرهانات مع اصدقائه
ونتحول الى البرازيلي بنسوس جونيور الذي
بث على بعد خطوه واحده فقط من تحقيق كل
احلامه رغم انه لم يبلغ من العمر 23 عام
وقبل عامين نشر لاعب ريال مدريد الاسباني
صوره عبره حسابي على الانستغرام كشف فيها
عن قائمه طفولته التي ضمت ثمانيه احلاما
تتعلقوا بمسيرته الكرويه وكما تظهر الصوره
شطب فينيسيوس سبعه منها قام بتحقيقها فعلا
ولم يتبقى له الا بالله حلمه الاكبر وهو
الفوز بلقب كاس العالم مع البرازيل
الختام مع كاميرا مدبلج الذي لم يلعب ولا
دقيقه مع منتخب استراليا في مونديال قطر
ومع هذا تمكن من العوده الى منزله بقميص
ميسي الذي ارتداه مع الارجنتين بعد انتهاء
مباراه دوري 16 شاهد كاميرا ميسي وهو يتجه
لغرفه الملابس فتبادل معه الحديث وطلب منه
قميصه وهو ما تم الا ان اللاعب الاسري خبئ
قميص البرغوث تحت كنزه التمرينات بهدف
العوده به خفيه الى منزله لكن وللاسف فرحه
فرحه دبل لم تضم طويلا فبحسب تصريحاته
الصحفيه حصل والده على القميص بعد عودته
للبيت هو مانعه ايضا من مجرد التفكير في
لمسه
[موسيقى]